start with mike trudeau
hey lebron i know you you always talk
about game one being a feel out game
was there anything that houston did
tonight that flummoxed you guys more
than
expected based on the week of watching
film and and knowing how they play with
this unique small ball group
that you saw on the court tonight um i
think it's the speed
they play with a lot of speed obviously
starting with the head of the snake and
rust
and they play with a lot of speed both
offensively and defensively
and you can watch it on film and you can
see it on film
uh until you get out there you get a
feel for it and that's what we did
tonight we got a feel for their speed
and
uh we should be fully aware of that
going into game two what's did it stand
out to you more on what you guys the
struggles offensively or defensively
could have both what was the thing that
stood out the most aside from the speed
i don't think we had any struggles
defensively um
obviously we allowed james to get to the
free-throw line way too much in the
first half
but more importantly i mean we had 17
turnovers for 27 points that's all
offense
and uh i thought defensively you know we
had a couple breakdowns but that
happened throughout the course of a
48-minute game but
i think i thought we were in tune on
that side but offensively we got to
clean up the turnovers
hey lebron it's dave it was a six-point
game to start the fourth
and houston went on a i think 12-3 run
um with a group that you guys haven't
really used before
what's it like to play with a a new
group of players
in a playoff situation when you've never
done it before
um you know who's ever on the floor we
got we gotta do a better job executing
and uh you know eg came in in the fourth
quarter and uh sparked them
um on offensive end you know getting to
the line getting into the paint
making shots and uh and we didn't get um
any to fall for us
so we got to do a better job of that
hey lebron so much coming into this
series is made of um
your guys's need to impose your will or
dominate inside however you want to
phrase it um what what do you think
needs to
happen on that front that didn't happen
tonight and how big of a part of that
was
the result oh we had 17 turnovers 27
points
and versus where's the team that's a
100 meter yard dash team um you you
cannot turn the ball over like that and
it's just that simple include
it starts with myself being the primary
ball handler
and trickles on everyone else so you
know we got to do a
got to be a complete turnaround going in
the game too
ally hey lebron
um i know generally when the game's
going on you stay pretty locked in
within the lines but
the banner being here and the other
families being here
did you draw anything from that presence
on the sideline today
um nah not really
you know it's definitely um blessing to
have my wife here
um but my kids are back in l.a still
my mom's back in ohio but i'm definitely
happy
that she's here uh it was just you know
but i keep the main thing the main thing
when i'm on the floor
uh when i'm on the floor it's all about
how i can be better for my teammates
um how can i you know make plays
offensively and defensively
and then um you know see my see my wife
after the game
say it again
um how do you adjust the team speed um
you understand that it's
you know it's not about just the legs
moving it's about the hand movement as
well
they're great with their hands um you
know you understand that if you have the
turnover you can't really relax you have
to
you have to get back quick twitch quick
twitch plays because they're very
extremely fast especially when rusk gets
adjusted that by you know playing
against it you know and uh
it's uh it's kind of like uh you know
in the early 2000s when the saint louis
rams uh the greatest show on turf
and people always say how do you scout
them and scout them and scout them
but until they got on the on the field
and they seen uh
isaac bruce and tory holt and marshall
fought
and as i keem and all those guys and it
was like okay we need
we need to play them again because
there's no way you can simulate that
speed
um so getting on getting out on the
floor and having a game one
give you a good feel for it
anyone else here question chris
how have you been able to adapt to how
you had to lay off now but adapted just
to
having to gain every other thing um
i mean it's been very challenging just
like
everything else has been challenging
here um and it is what it is there's no
excuses um
obviously the body takes a toll and and
things of that nature but you gotta
um you know i get right to work right
after the game win lose a draw you know
i started my treatment already in the
locker room i get back to the hotel i'm
gonna do some more
be up pretty pretty late tonight
hopefully i can get some rest tomorrow
during the day after our session
um but you know just start to prepare
for uh game two
and um you know i'm not the only one
everyone here um you know obviously if
you're able to close out a series you
get an opportunity to have a couple days
but once you get going
um it's every other day and you
understand that so you got to be
you know very smart about your about
your treatment sessions and getting in
your work but also staying off your feet
too
as well and um just preparing yourself
mentioning physically for for whatever
game is next
yeah last one on my end will be um
melissa
hey lebron you've talked a lot about
mindfulness and meditation i'm curious
when a game or a day does not
go your way in the bubble is there
something that you've learned to turn to
in the bubble to
help you reset mentally i'm
always talking about when i see my kids
i'm able to reset
and um you know that definitely helps um
a lot
you know definitely been a you know
extreme measures here
in the bubble uh you know mentally you
know stand sharp
uh mentally being in tune with yourself
um and being without your family for for
an extended period of time
it's something that uh not only myself
but a lot of guys that's here and
coaches
and everyone in general just um you know
haven't really had to go without
so you talk about essential parts of
your life you know
family always comes first so you know
having that out of your life you able
you know you have to put yourself in a
position where mentally you know what
centers you and uh for me uh meditating
helps
extremely a lot for me personally being
taking a lot of deep breaths and just uh
closing my eyes and just
centering myself and listening to my
inner self and things of that nature
and then but also like i said talking to
my kids talking to my mom
um you know that that definitely um you
know something that
you know keeps me you know in the blah
blah i guess you would say sane
um you know having that having that
support system even though they're not
here physically
all right thanks so much i appreciate it
all right um
hi welcome
is
alrighty tanisha ready when you are all
right
uh hi a.d we'll start off with um
mike trudell anthony it's mike back in
los angeles
lebron just talked about some of the
turnovers and stagnation
especially in that fourth quarter i
wondered what you saw from how houston
was playing you specifically
and how you think a better way or how
you think you could best attack
the way that they're trying to switch
and the way they're playing you
oh yeah they're trying to switch
everything um
you know they stay home in the post you
know i may
make some shots from there but uh
we just gotta you know lebron said
eliminator nervous
um we only had 15 we should have been
five or six but they it seemed like they
scored on every
turnover that we had i mean they had 27
points i'll turn over you know which
kills us so
um you know we can't turn the ball over
against this team
uh i mean that was kind of the big
big key you know we had some breakdowns
defensively
but and we kind of stopped running too
you know they'll make a shot
and you know we weren't getting the ball
out as quickly as we used to
and uh you know wasn't pushing the pace
so we got to get back to that game too
yeah anthony houston's basically played
the same eight guys you know first since
they got to the bubble
you're trying to work rondo back in now
but what do you think the key is to try
and get that continuity quickly
uh and so you guys are all on that same
string
he's a great uh player and a great
cerebral player so
he knows the game very well so it's not
going i don't think it'll take that much
time to get him back acclimated with the
team
um you know he made some shots that they
made some good plays for us
uh it's more so i i think his win uh
was fine today but playing in the game
and getting that game
that game uh you know conditioning is
it's tough and when you have a play and
then your first game is in a western
semi so
um just getting him back you know
acclimated with the team and then
trying to play from there and make some
adjustments and get ready for game two
hey anthony steve lebron said perhaps
the thing that
struck him the most about houston was
just their speed and
i wanted to know what was that that was
like for you to
kind of observe and catch up to speed
with them and
do you think the layoff affected the way
that impacted you guys they're a good
hit ahead team you know they get it off
the off the glass and they try to kick
ahead for early threes
which i think we did a good job of but
anytime
you know especially with russ and gets
the ball uh off a rebound
he's pushing and trying to get the layup
so you know it's about getting back and
loading to him and making sure that you
know he doesn't get to the basket
um and get easy layups or fouls same
with james
you know i think they got to the
following especially james early
um 11 free throws in the first half kind
of got his rhythm you know which created
a lot of
you know step back threes and things for
him like that so
keeping him off the free-throw line but
getting back in transition and
and loading up to those guys and making
them uh make different
different plays than what they used to
ally
hey um you it seemed like
uh pj and really
um did a pretty strong job keeping you
away from the rim and you were
obviously getting shots here mid-range
but is there something you see
or just think of offhand that might help
you
kind of get to the get to the rim more
and finish close to the basket
um yeah they're trying to just keep me
away from the rim um
you know we're trying to uh you know get
me off screens and things like that
but that's their defense you know even
when i'm there
um you know they're they're front to the
post and then they got guys on the back
side to
try to cover up for him so um i think we
make
a couple more shots it kind of opens it
up
like i said when i catch it down there
i'm getting the look that i want
um you know but same time you know i
think we
we had to do a better job with our
spacing and cutting and
so that way you know if they are in
front of you know flashing a guy and
things like that
uh working on the counters to to make
sure that
we make them pay for you know the
defense that they're trying to play
oh they're a good defensive team uh
especially since they've been here in
the bubble
um you know all their guys are like
sauce and they're able to switch
everything
kind of how golden state does you know
switching everything and then
just covering for each other you know
they're really good with their hands
so when you get to the to the paint you
know for a layup or whatever they're
they're
real good at stripping the ball away um
and getting steals and deflection so
um you know you got to be careful with
going into the paint
uh with the ball low and and also
the passes we usually have over the top
or lobs you know they're real good at
coming in and getting their hands on
them and deflecting those so
um you know our passion has to be a lot
better than it was tonight but
we make the right plays and we can make
them
last three on my end um what's the
michael duarte
so okay so we talked about uh their 27
points off of turnovers i'm wondering
if a lot of that is the three
three-pointers that you guys took you
guys took
38 three-pointers tonight just one less
than the rockets we expect the speed we
expect them to shoot a lot of threes
but uh are you falling into their hands
i guess by shooting as many threes as
they are and letting them get out in
transition with those long rebounds
a couple of them were you know were you
know tough shots but most of them were i
think it was great looks for us
you know got him in rotation and uh guys
got open looks our shooter got
got open looks um you know we just
didn't make
as many as we wanted but um no i don't
think we
were falling to their hands you know we
playing our style of basketball
um you know balling the poster and
making a read from there
uh but we i mean we got guys who can
shoot the ball as well you know
you know we can't come down and you know
shoot
bad shots we got to get good shots at
the room every time
you know and make sure we're playing
with pace and make them adjust to us
andy kaminsky hey anthony um your guys's
size advantage didn't give you the
advantage um
rebounding that would be expected what
did you see from houston
that made them successful in the class
tonight
um they do a good job of boxing out
i mean they know they understand they've
been playing this way um
for most of the year and you know they
do a good job of boxing out
making sure that you know teams don't
get don't kill them on the offensive
glass
so we got to do a better job of getting
rebounds if we continue to play big
you know we gotta we got to punish him
on on both ends
of the glass and making sure that you
know we get more rebounds and
use that to our advantage especially on
the offensive glass
you know i think they're taller guys pj
who's like six six
six seven or whatever and we got to do a
better job of attacking the old glass
and and making them pay for going small
last question harrison
a.d rondo was obviously gone a long time
i was just wondering for you
as a big guy like is that what are the
challenges of adjusting to having just
kind of a different playmaker back out
there on the floor for you
oh it's good for us because it kind of
give brown a break
um you know he's trying to make plays
with others
uh be in attack mode and so it gives ron
it gives him a break with rhonda on the
floor um
lebron kind of uh you know be that
that guy who can catch it and you know
just worry about attacking
um you know rondo's able to get in the
paint and make right plays and put guys
in their spots so
i think it's beneficial to us to have
him on the floor um
you know but like i said it's just about
getting him back acclimated with the
team and
you know getting his conditioning back
to where is all it is
thanks id thanks everyone have a good
evening